welcome back I am super excited today to introduce
you to the new second edition of our book
data-driven science and engineering by myself and
Nathan Kutz This truly is a labor of love this is
a subject both Nathan and I are super passionate
about and we really put a lot of ourselves into
the second edition so we're super happy with
it and I hope you get a ton of benefit out of
the things we added to this so I'm just going to
walk you through kind of what the motivation for
this book is what the philosophy is and what's
new in the second edition so you can decide if
this is something you want to read yourself and
chances are very good I will put a link in the
description to a PDF of this book so you can
read it usually for free let's uh you know stay
tuned for that down below okay so um this is the
second edition of a book that Nathan and I wrote
a number of years ago so the first version of this
book I think came out in 2019 we had been working
on it for about four or five years before that
I'm a professor in mechanical engineering with
adjunct appointments in applied math aerospace
engineering and computer science and engineering
Nathan Kutz is a professor with dual appointments
in applied math and electrical engineering and the
first edition of our book data-driven science
and engineering was really very much focused on
teaching emerging Technologies and machine
learning and data-driven methods to Engineers
okay so not just computer scientists but real
Engineers you know aerospace engineers mechanical
engineers electrical engineers and so on and so
forth who had deep domain knowledge and physics
knowledge we wanted to give them the tools in
machine learning dynamical systems and control
theory that are kind of driving the field forward
and similarly we wanted to give methods people
who are you know maybe in computer science or
applied math developing these new techniques
in in data intensive methods we wanted to give
them you know some insight into how their methods
could be really applied in physical systems and
Engineering Systems so kind of two big audiences
trying to tie it together here in this book
but the field changes so rapidly even in the
last three years things changed so much we needed
to to put out a second edition and I'll tell you
about what the features are in a minute so kind
of the philosophy that I take in this whole world
of you know how do I bring machine learning into
engineering is the following so behind these boxes
there's a bunch of cool fluid flows that's one
of my passions in engineering is fluid modeling
and flow control because it's so applicable to
nearly every trillion dollar industry whether
it's defense Health Care Transportation energy
you name it you know modeling and controlling
fluids is going to help us do that better and
machine learning is helping us model and controlfluids better.
it's helping with us with almost
all engineering tasks so at the end of the day
the philosophy I like to take and we definitely
take this in the book is that there are some
fundamental engineering tasks regardless of what
your discipline is things like modeling design
optimization sensor placement estimation and
feedback control this is just a small list of
many of the engineering tasks we have and at
the end of the day almost all of these tasks
end up being really hard optimization problems
they're hard because the physics is non-linear
and multi-scale usually in space and time which
leads to high dimensional non-convex optimization
problems and so one of the key ideas is that
machine learning is this process of building
models from data we have an increasing wealth of
data we have better optimization algorithms and
so we can build models from data with optimization
that's what machine learning is and we can start
solving some of these engineering tasks with these
machine learning models and with these emerging
machine learning optimization techniques if you
think about training a neural network that's a
high dimensional non-convex optimization problem
maybe we can use those same techniques when we try
to learn good sensor placement or some feedback
control law for a nonlinear problem so these
Technologies go really naturally together
engineering tasks are increasingly solvable
with machine learning models and data-driven
optimizations that's a perspective and to send
extent the reason this is true is because of
data so even you know very complex systems very
high dimensional systems whether it's you know
a network of neurons in your brain a disease
ripping across a continent or a very complex
geospatial fluid flow patterns exist in your
data you can compress that data you can extract
key features and you can use those with these
data intensive methods for modeling estimation
prediction and control and so our book starts
off with how extract these patterns from data and
then how do you use those patterns for modeling
for decision making for control for things like
that so we're very much focused on this idea of
how do you extract low dimensional patterns and
features from high dimensional data and then
how do you use that in an engineering context
for dynamical systems and control okay good
We've added a ton this is a very major overhaul
on the second edition. It's not just that we went
from Blue to Pink. We, for example... new to the
second edition we have new chapters, two entirely
new chapters: one on Reinforcement Learning and
one on Physics Informed Machine Learning.
These are two extremely exciting and rapidly developing
fields, that we thought
fit the theme of the book very well.
They're at this intersection of engineering
and machine learning, and so these are two
really exciting new chapters that we have added.
We have moved from having just Matlab code
in the first version... now every single code
is in Matlab and Python. We have Python codes
for every single example in the entire book.
And if you go to our website we
also have some codes in Julia, R, and C++...
in various stages of deployment. But
we have full code in Python and Matlab. In these
videos I notice the viewers want Python at least
three to one, so this was a huge overhaul for us.
We have videos for every single section of the
book, every chapter, there is
a video either by myself or by Nathan
on one of our two YouTube channels.
So if there is something you are reading about
and you're a little confused, go check it out
on YouTube, and maybe it'll make more sense
when we explain it to you in person.
Again something we're passionate about is
making sure you have lots of different
ways you can learn: you can read about them,
you can try to code them up yourself, you
can hear us give you a more classic
style lecture like this on our light board.
We have new sections throughout the entire
book. So in addition to these new chapters, most
of the existing chapters have new sections that
dive deeper into material we may have missed or
overlooked in the first edition.
So for example in our chapter on Fourier analysis
we added a new section on the Laplace transform, which is a super important for control theory and dynamics.
We overhauled the neural network section entirely because that field is movingso quickly.
Same with the data-driven dynamical
system, so lots of new sections throughout.
We also have homework for every single chapter...
extensive homework that was not there in the firstedition of the book.
Now we have homework for
every chapter, ranging from easy
to medium to research level projects, so you can
use this for classes if you want and really get
some inspiration... for how not just to to codify
the material and to learn by doing but
also to really get started on some research level
challenges and so some of the advanced homeworks.
These are the main changes... we found a
bunch of typos, Nathan and I are far from perfect,
there were a lot of typos in the first edition
it's much much cleaner in the second edition.
These are some of the big things we've
changed and I hope you like it. I hope you find
these new chapters to be really useful.
I hope you find the python code useful... many of you
were asking for this. I hope this
is really useful and you can actually use these
techniques more because of this this code and again this is a link databookuw.com/databookV2.pdf
This is a link I think this is currently a link
to the first edition of the book but we're going
to update this so you know hopefully by the time
you watch this there are links to the second edition
PDF of the book so you can go check this out
for yourself. If you like a paper copy
great, buy it. If you want to use this and have
a searchable version by all means and please do
it's website databookuw.com where we you
know we have each chapter broken up into
the video so you can go to our YouTube or
you can come here to databookuw.com it has
links to all of the code all the data sets
all the different languages all the videos
this is a pretty useful resource I
find myself going here pretty often
um Dynamics lab on GitHub this is our kind of
group GitHub repository between my group and
Nathan kutz's group and so we have lots and lots
of of repos here you'll notice Data Book Python
and data book Matlab that is a living repository
of all of the codes for every chapter of the book
so if you want to figure out how to make a robust
PCA algorithm in Python go here and go to chapter
three and download that code and it's there
for you without much you know much searching
early this is my YouTube channel Nathan has a
great YouTube channel also where you know all
of the sections in the book again are here
this is me presumably showing you the phase
portrait for a double well system but again
that's this is our light board setup where
every single video every single section really
is Illustrated um you know hopefully in a way
that helps you understand the material okay so
um that's the the mile high summary of the new
features in this book I'm so excited um you
know we really really were passionate about
making this we loved the first version we saw
a lot of potential to make the second version
even better and so I hope you like it too let us
know in the comments if there's things you want in
the Third Edition if there's things that you know
we did in the second edition that you really did
like or you know maybe made it harder for you or
easier so so do let us know all right thank you